hi I'm Aaron Maine and on YouTube is Mr
who's the boss and this is my wired
autocomplete interview
[Music]
oh my God I'm not safe
so Mr who's the Boss
where did the name Mr who's the boss
come from I think this is one of those
things where because I started the
channel when I was like 14 years old
I don't actually know I created this
channel not even knowing that I would
surpass 100 subscribers let alone like a
thousand ten thousand hundred thousand I
didn't even think it was possible for
YouTube to be a career at that point so
when I was deciding my username for it
it wasn't some big thing that I put a
lot of thought into yeah I feel like you
make the username and then before you
realize it that becomes your identity
and you don't really think about it
again
why is Mr who's the boss spelled wrong
I'll tell you what 20 million
subscribers
where was Mr who's the boss born so I'm
not a very mobile man I was born in a
city called Nottingham in the UK and I
lived probably five minutes from the
hospital I was born and then the one
time I've moved house I've now moved 10
minutes away from that hospital
what camera does Mr who's the boss use
so at the very beginning when I was
starting YouTube it was my dad's old
camcorder and all you'd see in the video
is my other hand holding the phone I was
talking about but as we started to level
up and improve our production value all
of our cameras have started to become
Sony cameras mostly because of how we
love the autofocus it's just you never
have to think about it again
what phone does Mr Hughes the boss use
I'm using an iPhone 13 Pro Max right now
mostly because of the battery life and
the fact that because I use a Mac iPhone
ties in really nicely with that but you
know I review phones for my living so
anytime a new Android phone comes out I
will take out my SIM card put it into
that phone and then try to insert that
phone into my life and see how well it
fits that's normally a pretty good way
to tell other people how good it is too
what font does Mr who's the boss use
trade secret what editing software does
Mr who's the Boss
[Music]
so I'm a big efficiency guy every
decision I make in my life is basically
geared around how can I do this as
quickly as possible and so I am a strong
advocate of Apple's Final Cut Pro
because it's really optimized for Apple
laptops but my entire editing team uses
Adobe Premiere Pro because it gives them
more flexibility so I let them have fun
key
is Mr who's the boss legit I guess it's
more important than ever to know if
someone's legit if that person is
deciding how you spend your money so
fair question but yes does Mr who's the
boss swear not at all in content I mean
I'm not much of a swearer anyway but I
think specifically for YouTube videos
it's not actually a good business
decision to swear because you completely
cut out kids from your audience but then
also YouTube doesn't like it they can
just demonetize you which is not great
either can Mr who's the boss speak Hindi
so as I was growing up I actually went
to two different schools I went to a
normal English school but then during
the weekends I went to Hindi school
where I just spent the entire time
learning the language and I also
distinctly remember my mum would tell me
that she wouldn't answer my questions
unless I asked them in Hindi which is a
very good way of teaching a kid to learn
a language properly
what car does Mr who's the boss Drive I
actually have a bit of a philosophy on
this I drive a very simple car so I
remember a point a couple of months ago
where a Tesla a car that I'd really
really been wanting for like a long long
time suddenly came up as available and
that's quite rare in today's car market
so I remember telling myself okay I'm
gonna Reserve this car but then over the
course of the next couple of days I
started really thinking about it and I
started thinking is this how I want to
get my dream car is it just a case of oh
it's available let me click order I
think it almost takes the fun out of it
I almost feel like there needs to be a
journey of progression like you need to
be able to save it for one of your big
goals that you achieve in the future not
just buy it because you feel like it so
I decided to cancel the pre-order and to
set it as a future goal
who did Mr who's the boss outro song you
know the funny thing is it's actually a
royalty-free track so before I put this
song as my outro on YouTube the original
video of the song had about a thousand
views then two months after it was our
outro it was on about 150 200 000 just
because we were playing it again again
at the end of our videos and people
people just loved it we love that outro
song so much that I actually remember
trying to stalk the DJ who created it I
like found her on Instagram sent her a
message being like we love your song so
much can you please do a custom version
for our Channel
nothing
when does Mr he's the boss sleep this is
a very topical question I'm part way
through a health transformation kick
right now so I basically give myself 100
days to turn my life around because it
got to a stage a while ago where YouTube
kind of caught up with me I was
overweight I was sleeping three hours a
night I was I was stressed all the time
so I knew it had to change and I was
like why do I just invite my viewers
along with me on the journey so one of
the ways that I'm trying to fix myself
is to sleep at 11 PM every single night
and it's actually really hard but one
thing that's actually really helping
with that is I am meditating before I
sleep and that's actually really really
good at helping you just to forget about
the whole day and all the stresses that
come with it it's kind of sad but yeah I
have a strict bedtime now
can you trust Mr who's the boss so I
actually made a video with this exact
title about a year ago and the reason
was to try and address this
misconception that you can't really
trust YouTubers because YouTubers can
take a lot of money to just say nice
things about a product I try really hard
for that to not be me so like any time I
do a sponsored video on a product I will
have actually asked that company to send
that product beforehand before I signed
the agreement to say I'm going to cover
it which is a long way of saying yes
let's go this way
how to contact Mr who's the boss leave a
comment on this video and I will try to
reply to you
how many subscribers does Mr who's the
boss have well this is actually the core
thing so on the main Channel we have
just under 11 million but because of the
second shorts Channel that's kind of up
and coming and growing really fast the
total amount is like 16 million now
which is a wild number to me how to
enter Mr who's the boss giveaway um I
haven't done a giveaway in a while but
when I do them I tend to tell people to
enter this giveaway just be subscribed
and follow my social accounts I'm never
going to ask you to give me your details
so I can send you spam emails if that's
the question how tall is Mr he's the
boss I'm six foot or six foot one if you
count the hair how many cats does Mr
who's the boss have I have two cats I
have Simba who's the first categor and
then Milo about three years later and as
soon as Milo came into the house he
stole everyone's heart he has the most
human personality of any cat I've ever
met I've got a photo of him as my
wallpaper I don't know if you can see
this this is him as a baby
foreign just like to say this chair is
an experience there's multiple angles I
feel like I could fall from
Mr who's the boss favorite tech I test a
lot of tech and you come to realize that
the best tech is the tech that you don't
have to think about the tech that just
works in the background of your life and
lets you do what you want to do but that
inherently makes it a little bit boring
so my favorite piece of tech are the
useless fun gimmicky things that you
don't need like I was testing a pair of
gloves recently that allow you to make
phone calls by holding your hands like
this that stuff's brilliant I also
really really love gaming but because I
don't have as much time to play myself
anymore I kind of enjoy it by watching
other people play on YouTube right Mr
who's the boss Finnish Tech so this is
referencing one of our most successful
videos and that video is basically a
compilation of the thinnest heck that I
could find in the entire world and it
all resulted in basically a paper thin
usable smartphone literally the size of
like 40 to paper Mr who's the boss Tech
pranks okay so this is referencing our
YouTube short Channel and the crazy
thing about that shorts Channel which is
just like 60 second videos is that that
has now overtaken the main channel in
views after one year it's on almost two
billion which is just ludicrous and
probably like my most successful series
on that shorts channel is Tech pranks
where it's basically just I tell people
how they can use technology To Lose
Friends there's one that I can remember
off the top of my head it's pure evil
where you install a Chrome extension on
your friend's laptop and what it means
is that every single time they open a
new tab there is a one in a hundred
chance that it pulls up a massive face
of Nicholas Cage it's subtle enough that
they will never actually realize
something's wrong
Mr who's the boss inventions this is
another recent series that we started on
the channel where I basically just
scoured the internet for all the
absolute coolest things happening across
the entire world and the benefit of this
series is that because I don't need to
physically have the stuff in my hand the
scope of what you can cover is much
broader one of the coolest ones that I
can think of off the top of my head is
there is a building that is covered in
kind of like an algae type thing and
that algae through photosynthesis
generates the electricity to run that
building and it lasts forever oh and it
also cleans up the air around it because
it's taking in the carbon dioxide it's
not genius
oh my God I'm not safe
how is Aaron Meenie I'm doing fantastic
Aaron me any chess chess is actually a
huge part of my life so the way that
chess became a big part of my life is my
dad had a sports injury and while he was
in hospital for like a prolonged period
of time one of the only things he had
was a chessboard so he just played chess
like all day while stuck in this
hospital bed and he became very
passionate about this game and this was
around the time when he had me and so he
thought I'm going to teach him how to
play chess and so I got better and
better and better the day I beat my dad
was something pretty special and then
eventually at the age of about 15 I
qualified for the England chess team to
represent the country there was a
European championship in Gibraltar
against like Poland France other
countries like that it's not a glamorous
sport but for me it was my entire life
like I'd I dreamed as a kid of being in
the England team so it was a real like
Fanboy moment actually being there when
did Aaron Maney graduate college I don't
know at the top of my head I graduated
about five years ago and that was the
same time that I jumped straight into
YouTubers a full-time career so the best
decision I'd ever made in my entire life
what language does Aaron mainey speak I
speak English
what is our mainly doing now
I'm gonna place this one down actually
so that's my wide autocomplete
sorry about the ceiling but this has
been fun if you want to subscribe to
Wyatt that's down below don't subscribe
too much I don't want them to beat me
thank you